a lot of rumors out there about you
you've had a lot of stuff in your life
about music
art
and i'm hearing that you might have a
thing where you want to get into
politics and stuff like that
are you serious yeah i'm serious man i
mean no
but if i mean how much does it how much
is the how much they pay you to be the
president only thing only way i do with
politics is if you know how people can
go viral or song can just magically go
viral from 10 years ago 20 years ago if
somebody did a dale dan tony for
president campaign and that [ __ ]
actually went they're like well he's
over 35. well he's born in america well
you know what we gave [ __ ] uh [ __ ]
weekend to bernie's guy
we gave him we gave [ __ ] you know
what i mean we gave carl from home depot
the [ __ ] president was like just to
get the other guy out like [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
let's go the rock rock's like no i got
movies to shoot [ __ ] you golden tony and
everybody's like you know what like
let's just get a [ __ ] american
[ __ ] real actual man in there to
[ __ ] run the show and and and
listen to the people and do all this
[ __ ] i do it
but it's not it's not like that but is
it some so you would do it if it came to
you if it came knocking on your door you
would do it put it like this it's it's
like everybody asked me dude like oh you
should have podcast you should do all
these you know have a pocket
i i don't feel like i i could set that
up and organize that the only way i i
would do that
is if like you were like oh you know
what i'm going to
fully set up this riff-raff podcast and
then and then show me the division
coming from
someone who's who's already massively
successful in it so it would have to be
something from
the world and they want it
they want it and they put it together
and [ __ ] it i'll be i'll be president
and uh now actually try
but me doing the whole campaign and
actually trying to be president or
trying to be i'm gonna be the [ __ ] a
mayor you could start with a mayor city
council with city council sounds like a
lot of work a lot of suits a lot of dry
cleaners
a lot of luncheon can i bring my dogs i
think these are questions that i'm like
i gotta even ask the hoax what's some of
the rules you do right when you get in
there they put you in there man
are we talking mayor or talking
president
um
i would say senate or lieutenant or like
governor lieutenant first of all i'm
like all right where y'all got me
staying at
is it a guard gated
senate penthouse
so you want that upstairs spot i need
them upstates yeah
we're gonna like what what are the per
what are you what like i need to know
where i'm at where i could set up
is there a homeowners association in my
home
are y'all giving me a house or just
giving me a whole bunch of [ __ ] to do in
a pile of papers and be like oh you got
to find your own trailer so you want
housing
not just housing
my bad
big
a
just give me an
arena okay all right all right
corrugated and what you're gonna do
though if you use the remote
that goes around the entire thing and
one drawbridge goes down
that's what we're doing first we'll
build a moat all right
10 feet because nobody's 10 feet tall
alligators
and then what piranhas
oh damn
do alligators and piranhas even get
along we don't know
so imagine if you fell in that you got
i'm not doing that they're already been
practicing oh i ain't being in that room
no so when they have to try to get me
out after them four years or i don't
know what is it two and a half months if
your senate
i don't know what it is they just shot
that one guy see
oh like
fame isn't even
stain said oh you you want that smoke
baby you put my grandma in the prison
in 86. yeah i'm like i just started
being senate you didn't get my grandma
you're
your
your great grandfather put my
grandfather in a headlock
yeah you know yeah now i'm dealing with
the pr previous
prior terms agreement you're dealing
with old [ __ ] you used to steal steel
cinnamon your great-grandfather stole
cinnamon from somebody i knew
you stole the si you stole cinnamon
toast crunch idea your uncle rodney yeah
he had had his fist so far up my ass
he took my ideas
he took my identity
i'm having an identity crisis
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one